معنا من خانيونس مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل
ابو عمر اسماعيل المزيد حول ما رصد تموه
من تطورات
ميدانيه نعم الذي يسلم من القصف او من
التجريف عبر اله الحرب الاسرائيليه خلال
الايام الماضيه تطاله طائرات الاحتلال حيث
تدمر هذه الطائرات منازل مواطنين ومنشات
سكنيه وكذلك منشات صناعيه على مدار الوقت
فجر هذا اليوم او الليله الماضيه قامت
طائرات الاحتلال الحربيه بقصف محطه للوقود
في منطقه عبسان الكبيره بالقرب من مستشفى
غزه الاوروبي ايضا اثار هذا القصف وشظايا
هذا القصف طالت المستشفى هناك اضرار بالغه
وقعت في احد اقسام مستشفى غزه الاوروبي
اضافه الى قطاع التيار الكهربائ الكهربائي
داخل اقسام المستشفى اضافه الىى ذلك هناك
شهيد نتيجه هذا القصف وسته اصابات وصلت
الى مستشفى غزه الاوروبي بسبب هذا القصف
العنيف الذي وقع في منطقه عبسان الكبيره
اضافه الى هذا القصف ايضا هناك غارات
نفذتها طائرات الاحتلال الحربيه على اكثر
من هدف في منطقه خانيونس وفي المنطقه
الفاصله بين خان يونس ورفح منطقه ميراج
منطقه حي المناره هذه المناطق تشهد خلال
اليومين الماضيين غارات عنيفه على شكل
احزمه ناريه تنفذها طائرات الاحتلال
الحربيه وتدوي انفجارات ضخمه وكبيره في
مناطق جنوب قطاع غزه تصيب المواطنين خاصه
من النازحين الذين يقطنون في بعض المناطق
القريب من هذا القصف تصيبهم بحاله من
الهلع والفزع والخوف نتيجه شده هذه
الغارات والتي تتم على ساعات متواصله
احيانا في هذه المناطق في منطقه غرب خان
يونس ما زال القصف مستمر حتى هذه الساعه
خاصه القصف المدفعي والذي يستهدف محيط
مستشفى الامل بالقرب او في حي الامل
تحديدا في منطقه المشروع في غرب محافظه
خان يونس والاشتباكات ايضا ما بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال في
اكثر من منطقه في اكثر من المحور في
محافظه خانو مستمره خاصه في منطقه وسط
البلد حيث هناك بلاغات عسكريه من المقاومه
الفلسطينيه سواء كتائب القسام سراء القدس
وكتائب شهداء الاقصى وغيره من التشكيلات
العسكريه عن استهدافات لقوات الاحتلال
استهدافات لاليات الاحتلال استهدافات
لجنود الاحتلال عبر استخدام قذائف مضاده
للدروع كذلك تفجير عبوات ناسفه في جنود
الاحتلال واليات الاحتلال المتوغلة
فلسطينيه وتتم احيانا على مسافه صفر ما
بين رجال المقاومه وكذلك قوات الاحتلال
الذين يتمركزون ويعتلي ازل مواطنين في
محيط مستشفى الامل في حي الامل في غرب
محافظه خانيونس في منطقه المعسكر ما زالت
الاليات على حالها تتقدم وتتراجع احيانا
من بعض المناطق وتقوم في حاله التقدم وحال
التراجع ايضا بقصف مدفعي في محيط منطقه
معسكر خان يونس او مخيم خان يونس للاجئين
في تلك المنطقه اضافه الى طلقات ناريه
تطلق بين الحين والاخر من هذه الاليه
التي ما زالت تتواجد على الارض في منطقه
معسكر خانس تحديدا بالقرب من محطه عبد
الهادي اضافه الى الحي الياباني في حي الى
الغرب من حي الامل كل هذه المناطق ما زالت
تتواجد فيها اليات الاحتلال وتتمركز فيها
وتقوم بعمليات قصف عنيف بين الحين والاخر
سواء باطلاق نار وكذلك قذائف مدفعيه تطلق
باتجاه منازل المواطنين من خانيونس مراسل
الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر شكرا جزيلا لك